ا سنبدا هذه المره من شمال قطاع غزه الذي
لا يزال يشهد معارك عنيفه في اكثر من
منطقه بين كتائب القسام وفصائل المقاومه
والجيش الاسرائيلي السبب في اننا سنبدا من
شمال القطاع لان الشمال حقيقه بالمعنى
الميداني لا يزال يشكل عقده قتاليه
ومفاجاه على هذا المستوى الشمال هي احد
ابرز المناطق التي شهد قتالا استمر
لاسابيع
بين القوات الاسرائيليه وبين كتائب
المقاومه اسرائيل تستمر بالقول انها انهت
هذه المهمه لكن هناك تطورات يوميه لا سما
في حيي التفاح والدرج مازال وهما من احياء
مدينه غزه ما يزالان مراكز اشتباك قويه
بين الجيش الاسرائيلي وبين كتائب المقاومه
هناك استه دا فات في هذان المكانين
واشتباكات توصف بانها عنيفه جدا طبعا
المنطقه شرق مدينه غزه تحديدا هناك
اشتباكات على اكثر من محور ولكن هذه
المحاور ليست ثابته بمعنى ليس هناك تمركز
دائم للقوات الاسرائيليه على سبيل المثال
في التفاح او في الدرج او الريس وهي
والشعف وهي الاحياء الخلفيه ولكن ما يحدث
هو ان الاسرائيليين مثلا يق يقومون
بعمليات توغل ضرب ضرب اهداف والتراجع
قليلا الى ما وراء خط صلاح الدين هذا هو
خط صلاح الدين ففائدة
وشوارع غزه مكان اشتباك وايضا بعض المناطق
الخارجيه مثل جباليا و ومخيم جباليا ولكن
الشوارع الخارجيه في هذه المناطق لان قوات
الاحتلال نفذت بالفعل انسحابات من داخل
الاحياء والبلدات في شمال القطاع وهي
تتركز بشكل اكثر تحديدا عند مداخله وفي
نقاط ربما تكون استراتيجيه للقتال بالنسبه
لها
بالانتقال الى وسط قطاع غزه وسط قطاع غزه
مخيم البريج ايضا ما زال منطقه قتال
مستمره القوات الاسرائيليه تحاول بشكل
مكثف اختراق مخيم البريج قالت انه احد اهم
الاهداف في وسط قطاع غزه حتى الان لم تدخل
اليه كتائب القسام ه تستهدف
القوات المتقدمه وتوقع بها خسائر شاهدنا
مؤخرا امس بالتحديد صور اقمار صناعيه تظهر
استهداف لتجمعات تجمع اليات عسكريه بالقرب
من
مخيم من مخيم البريج وهناك استهداف مباشر
ما اضطر القوات للتراجع عن الاماكن التي
تتمركز فيها الجديد اليوم هو مخيم السراط
اليوم قوات الاحتلال اصدرت امرا باخلاء
على الاقل سبعه احياء من مخيم ان سيرات
يبدو ان هناك توجه بعد البريج
محاوله اقتحام مخيم ان سيرات المخيمات
مدنيه وكثيفه كثيفه السكان وايضا كثيفه
المباني سننتقل سريعا الى خان يونس في
اقصى الجنوب في جنوب قطاع غزه خان يونس ما
تزال ايضا محور اشتباك عنيف جدا
الاشتباكات بحسب المصادر الميدانيه لا
تتوقف قوات الاحتلال تحاول اختراق المدينه
لم تتمكن من الدخول اليها لكن اقتربت من
بعض الاحياء هنا هناك شيء المبنى البلديه
في مدينه خانيونس القوات الاسرائيليه
تتمركز عند مبنى
المدنيه البلديه عفوا وتحاول اختراق وسط
مدينه خان يونس ولكن القتال ضار وايضا
هناك نقاط اشتباك عند اقصى شرق خان يونس